all right so we'll start again with the
the second talk of this session where
it's my pleasure to introduce Tim we're
tell talk to us about minimal support
for lattices insane okay thank you very
much for the invitation and thanks for
the introduction
so fittingly for the workshop I will try
to address like all the four key words
of the workshop so obviously I'm going
to talk about lettuces I'll try to apply
some geometry and I'll talk about some
algorithmic aspect and just to take the
last book I'll open like opposed a open
hardness question just to have
everything there so the topic I want the
things I want to talk about today is
joint work with these kind of earlier
also from part of Gennady avakov he's
known Btu corpus and this sustained yoga
from UC Davis so the problem I want to
look at is the integer feasibility
problem in standard form so I assume I
have some linear constraints ax equals B
and then I'm just going to add some
positivity constraints and my question
is whether we can find I mean the
finding part of the key not the
important part but I'm interested in
integer solution to this problem and
then in particular I want to ask the
question whether we can find actually
solutions where the support is not too
large so by that I mean can we say
anything about solutions to an integer
feasibility program on the number of
nonzero components to make my life a
little easier I'm not going to address
at all the problem of actually finding
for the solution and whether it's
feasible so usually I'll just actually
assume that the B is of such kind that
the problem has actually some integer
solution and then secondly I'm gonna
assume that the GCD of all the minors of
my matrix a is equal to one this is
mainly to make my life easier and maybe
yours a little bit as well but it's
actually not a big assumption
essentially what I'm just saying is that
if I look at all integer combinations of
the columns of
they just spam the letters said em or
alternatively the Hermit normal form for
example is just the identity of this
matrix and if this would not be in her
like if this condition would not hold I
would just actually divide everywhere by
the GCD of the matrix a maybe there's
some among you that don't like integer
programming not a problem you can just
reformulate this problem a little bit
and consider it as follows I mean just
consider the matrix a as a set of n
columns and we just consider the semi
group which is generated by all positive
combinations of these columns then
obviously I'm interested in elements in
the semi group that would be in this
setting our B and then the question is
what is the minimum number of elements
like from the generators do I need
actually to generate the element B and
then there's no integer programming a
gamma okay so here I'm just looking at
all
so I've the set of integers 1 2 n I'm
just selecting all M subsets so and then
a gamma is just the M times n matrix
with columns gamma so that's just the
minors
okay so the first thing that we can have
a look at is maybe before we go to the
integer setting is what do we know for
the linear program so what is if we drop
the assumption that we want to have
integer solutions but just continuous
solutions and then things are actually
quite well known at least if we want to
have bounds because now we're actually
not looking at anything else then I'm
looking at B which are in the cone spent
by the columns of a and then we can just
use cavity or Dovie and he'll tell us
that we can always find some vector X
such that with support less or equal
than M such that 8 and X star is
precisely equal to B so going back again
to the integer setting if you would like
I mean I'm asking something like a
looking for equivalent cut at your
Dooley type statement just for the
integer setting okay so what can we hope
for I mean this bound for the continued
setting is of course it's very nice we
just have an M can we expect anything
similar for the integer setting I guess
probably it's rather obvious that this
will be no I mean otherwise I think most
of us would actually have to look for a
new job and they're already like a
number of results so let's start with a
very nice and positive case so if we
impose some additional structure on our
matrix a and this setting if we assume
that a the columns of a actually form a
hilbert basis so by that I mean if I
look at the semigroup of a is precisely
equal to the integer sets integer points
within the cone of that is spanned by a
itself if we have this additional
structure there was first a result by
Cooke from the inscriber and they showed
that in this setting you can always
guarantee that you need at most 2 m
minus 1 elements to generate any element
in the
I'm semigroup and then at 40 a few years
40 years later she bore and managed to
improve this a little bit and brought it
down to 2 and minus 2 and then I think
also for quite a while there was the
open question whether one could bring it
all the way down to M so get the
equivalent bound as for the continuous
setting and there it was Boone's couplet
its Martin Hank Martin and Martin Hank
and Rob member they showed that actually
you cannot get a better bound than 7
over 6 times M so you definitely don't
get beg no further than for the cavity
or door be rank and it's actually still
a quite interesting open question where
the precise bound is wasted I think
quite a lot of time trying to improve
anything but it didn't find anything
significant so that's on the positive
side if we want to now go a little bit
more general and assume less structure
on 8 things are going to change a little
bit so there's the one setting where I
just look at the maps RK so setting M
equals 1 and they're a few years ago
together with early Earth and others
were able to show that when can just
guaranteed that the support is less or
equal than 1 plus the maximum the
logarithm of the maximum entry of our
constraint matrix a and in the more
general setting where m is not
necessarily 1 2006 there is a nice
result by isin plant and join and they
showed that the support is bounded
roughly by something like m times the
logarithm of the maximum energy of a and
this we were also able to improve a
little bit we were able to show then
also in the same paper of 2017 that we
can always bound this from above by M
plus the logarithm of the determinant of
a times a transpose M in the square root
of that
Oh briefly show where this term comes
from a little later and also for another
purpose of that I want to get back
likely to him in this we can just
rewrite with caution be near in this way
and if you just want to be able to
compare it to the result but isin blunt
you can actually upper bound this bound
again just in terms of the maximum entry
if you like and then we see at least it
is a tiny improvement that we got like
the M 2 square root and maybe similar we
can ask ourselves like for the hilbert
basis case and whether one can actually
do a lot better and we were actually
able also to give lower bounds and we
will not be able to reduce the lorda
significantly so one can actually
construct examples where you need at
least something like M times the
logarithm of the maximum entry to the
power of 1 minus M small epsilon so will
not be able to improve much but there's
still some gap and maybe one last note
is also that if we want to move on to
the like an optimization problem so
we're looking for an optimal sparse
solution it turns actually out that the
same bound actually holds so we can also
find an optimal sparse solution that
fulfills this inequality and what I'm
going to one of the things I want to
show you today is that actually this
kind of freedom that we had to get to
the optimal solution we can actually
also use to improve this bound a little
bit and in particular this will give
some nice improvements for the knapsack
case
okay but maybe just before I go on there
I might want to go one step backward and
just ask the question of finding like a
sparse solution for a - teen system of
linear equations and surprisingly to the
best of my knowledge I mean we haven't
been able to find any results in this
direction even though you would think
that everything has been done on - teen
systems of equations
the only kind of exception that goes a
little bit in this direction is for
example these Eagle types lemma that for
example look at finding short solutions
I mean if you want to think of it a
little bit I mean this sparsity you can
also think of like a semi norm so we're
also looking to minimize a norm and
that's essentially like the closest that
we've seen that comes into this
direction and actually this is also
precisely where this square root of
Delta determinant of a times a transpose
comes from in the previous result I
employed this okay so before going on
again to the semigroup case I would like
to first just look a little bit at this
easier I'm sad tank where we don't have
positivity constraints and here we can
actually give also tight results and for
that I would just quickly like to
introduce some notation so assume that I
have some integer said I hope we all
know that they're each integer has like
a unique prime factorization and then we
can like count various things and what I
want to account is the multiplicities of
these prime factorizations so if I
haven't said then the prime Omega
function is just the function that
counts the multiplicities and then going
one step further we can actually also
look at something like what we call the
truncated prime Omega function is where
we kind of just count them with implicit
ease and if the multiplicities are too
large we just found it by recap it by
some
integer m and then also immediately I
mean I'm also from number theory there's
like this little Omega function which
just counts the number of different
prime factorizations and just to link it
again to the previous so the results
what we have is I mean we have just like
this nice chain of inequalities that a
little Omega function is lesser e lesser
than the truncated Omega function which
is lesser for them but Omega function
and clearly that is then again less or
equal than just a logarithm of Zed and
equality we only have precisely when the
Zed is a multiple of like a something 2
to the power of something and what is
nice here is a little bit I mean so I
said I mean the Equality only happens
like when said is a power of two but an
average actually it is way better and
just using that the prime number theorem
one can actually showed that for a hand
wave with a little bit of expectation is
more of the size log log said and with
this notation or we can actually show
for the - teen system of equations is
that if we first select any kind of non
singular n times n square matrix then we
can always find for any integer right
inside be some vector X star such that
of course a times X star is equal to B
and the support is no larger than M plus
the truncated Omega a value of the
determinant of Delta of our non singular
matrix a
okay
I'll just roughly outline the proof idea
and it is actually quite easy just to
show that this statement holds it if we
just remove the M here so I'll just
focus on that setting because it's
easier so the proof idea here is not
overly complicated and what we actually
do is we should show a slightly stronger
statement namely better if we have a
matrix a we actually always can find
subselection of columns of a that
contain our subset of indices that
respond to tell and a few more and in
total we have then just the this number
of columns and if we just take this
selection we can guarantee that the
lattice that is spent by this a of gamma
is precisely equal to the lattice that
is spanned by all elements of a and by
our previous and assumption this would
be nothing else
and the idea is then just to look at the
related groups so what we can do is just
look at the quotient group that is
defined by matters like said M with
respect to the lattice that we spent by
a of Tull then we know precisely from
geometry of numbers that I mean the
number cardinality of this group the G
tau is precisely the just the number of
integers with and a half-open parallel
piped defined by the earlier papers of a
tall so this kind of defines my matrix a
then we see I think this should be
precisely 10 points so the group is of
size 10 and now if we don't span yet the
whole lattice set M of course there must
be some column a that is not contained
in this letter letters spent by a of tau
so we can just take this element take
this medium sized dot and then add it to
our selection of columns and we
immediately get that this gives us a
subgroup of G of tau and in particular
we know then that the cardinality of G
of gamma beg the new set must divide G
of tau and with that we can actually
guaranteed that the Omega function
strictly decreases and then we can just
reiterate this process until we cover
the whole of Z M and we're actually done
for this truncated thing we just need to
add a few more extra steps but I would
not want to go to detail here ok so this
is I think rather nice and we can
actually get to that in a moment of a
door it's actually also best possible
but going back again now to our initial
problem that we initially were looking
at so we do have positivity constraints
this immediately gives like a nice easy
corollary just by allowing like now if
we just allow the setting
have the additional assumption that the
cone of a actually spans the whole space
then we're more or less in the setting
as in the lettuce case and we just have
to add like a two in front of our M and
we can guarantee that we will always
find actually a positive integer
combination of B where we don't use more
than two M plus the Omega M of
determinant value
and maybe just on this part a few final
remarks I mean if we get any value for
this Omega function we can actually
always construct an M times some n
matrix where the where the n actually
depends then on the value that we put
here where we have precisely equality so
we can't do any better here and then
from the proof we've already seen it is
actually rather constructive so we can
actually compute like these relatively
sparse solutions and if we would like to
drop this from the scolari this
assumption that the current spends
actually RM we get like at least the
statement that most of the right-hand
sides B have a relatively small support
like minimal support that is just from
the fact that if you look at the cone
spanned by a difficulty thing
difficulties only arise at the boundary
and if you just exclude the boundary
points you actually can just apply this
statement
okay so this is actually I mean
obviously a significant improvement over
the bounds that we've seen previously
like for the general settings and the
next question is can we actually get
like a proper statement and then also
pointed coins for example and that will
be my next step thing I want to look at
and I want to assume now that my that
the cone generated by the columns of a
is actually pointed cone and if alright
if it's a pointed cone of course there
must be an extreme rate on this cone and
I'll just gonna assume that my first
column a one is actually an extreme rate
and in this setting we can actually now
guarantee that the minimum support of
any solution feasible solution can
always be bounded by M plus 1/2 the
logarithm of this sum here and if you
remember I in the previous statement
like in the previous results we had
actually the same result where we just
didn't have that the 1 has to be in the
Gamma so what we were able here what we
were able to do here is reduce and the
number of summands by a factor of M over
N there's necessarily need to be any
better because I mean in theory all
these Delta determinants of alpha gamma
could be 0 but for general matrices this
is actually an improvement I don't want
to go into detail actually for of the
proof of this but I want to actually
focus on the setting where m is again
equals to M because things actually
become a lot easier and nicer so if we
assume that M is actually 1 then asking
for the cone a 1 to a n to be pointed as
nothing else to either say that all I
want a n are positive or all of them are
negative and extreme rays we only have
two extreme rays in the two-dimensional
setting either the minimum value or the
maximum value and what we can actually
do then is
reduce things I mean also this summit is
just a single term then and we get that
if we have the positive vector a and we
have a feasible knapsack problem then we
can actually say that we find a feasible
solution X star where the support is
actually 1 plus now the minimum entry of
a 1 to M and that's like an improvement
over the maximum entry that we had
beforehand and I mean obviously this is
a calorie of the theorem but I can prove
the caller really relatively easily and
I'll try to do this I mean this is a
nice little application of makovski and
any application of Minkowski is always a
good application my opinion ok so at its
core is this little lemma so if my T is
larger strictly larger than 1 plus the
logarithm of the first entry a 1 then if
I look at this following system of
equations so I want to have that why I
plus AI summing up over those sum up to
0 so it's an element in the kernel of
the vector of a 1 to 80 I want that my
vectors Y I is non trivial so at least
one element has to be nonzero and I want
to have that the first element is just
positive and the remaining ones should
just be elements minus 1 0 4 1 if we
assume that this lemma is true then
deriving the khawarij is actually
relatively straightforward so first
we've just may assume by reordering that
a1 is the minimum element of the numbers
a 1 to a n and now instead of looking
for this Parsis solution ax equals B I'm
gonna look for the Sparsit solution
where I minimize the support on x2 to xn
so I'm kind of ignoring for the moment
the first variable x1 and then again
just by reordering I may assume that the
first T elements are all strictly
positive and the remainings are
the remaining entries are zero from this
solution and now should it happen that
actually T is larger than one plus the
logarithm of my smallest entry a 1 and I
can apply the lemma and I can just
construct K and take this Y extended by
some zeros and add it to my ex and I can
actually strictly decrease the support
of X contradicting this minimum ok so it
just remains to argue why the lemma is
true and here the idea is actually to
apply in Coffs keys first theorem and
what I'm going to look at first is these
constraints and these constraints and
I'm gonna relax them as far as possible
so instead of saying that a 1 times y I
plus all the way to YT times 80 is equal
to 0 I can just say as well that it is
strictly larger than minus 1 and
strictly less than 1 any integer
solution of course will then be equal to
0 and similarly I can relax the integer
constraints for the second for these for
the constraints that I want to be minus
1 0 or 1 by just saying that these my
eyes are supposed to be strictly larger
than minus 2 and strictly less than 2
I'm going to look at this ciliary
polytope I can rewrite it a little bit
just in terms of the maximum maximum
norm where I define just this the matrix
of this form and now it's just an easy
volume argument so we know that Q is
just equal to 1 divided by the
determinant of M times the volume of our
the cube with edge length 2 and then
with our assumption that T is strictly
larger than 1 plus the logarithm of a 1
we get that this volume of this poly
tope is actually strictly larger than 2
to the T we can apply man coughs key so
there must be a non-trivial integer
point in this point and by our
constraints we know that all the entries
of the wise has to be either
- 1 0 or 1 and we only have some freedom
for the first variable but since our
queue is actually centrally symmetric
just by flipping the vector we can
always just assume that also the first
injuries okay that completes the proof
of this this is not constructive now
unfortunately not I mean only in the
other setting we're able actually to
prove something over rhythmically
obviously finding sparse solutions is
np-hard I mean even for the continuous
setting but but even we're getting an
approximation with this bound is
actually I wouldn't know how immediately
now but this actually also leads me to
my last slide so you brought it up
already I mean if we just look at
specific right hand side be finding a
sparse solution is actually np-hard you
might be able to find approximations I
actually don't know anything about this
but what we can we can go actually a
step further and define something like I
would call the integer cardioid all the
rank of a matrix a and if we look about
at all positive possible right-hand
sides B that we get so it's just eight
times some positive right inside integer
vectors said and I look at the minimum
support of those can we say anything
about this term can we compute this and
on the positive side what we can say is
actually that if we fix the dimension
where the matrix a lives and so if we
fix n obviously this also will fix then
M then we can actually say that we can
compute the integer code or be ranked in
polynomial time and what we can do here
is just reduce things essentially to
counting points and then just using like
generating functions this is like
ongoing work that we're currently on and
as I promised to also pose at least one
hardness question
what we weren't able to do is actually
prove that computing the integer card
they all ranked this empty hard we kind
of finished my talk with this open
question made this last part you mean I
mean we do believe there must might be
some kind of similarities because I mean
like the behavior is quite similarly we
can formulate things in these
Pressburger arithmetic like for all K
there exists something on words but I
mean the support itself I'm not aware
that there's any direct connection to
frobenius
so what we can actually do here is I
mean look like on a high level I can
just do is if we want to look whether we
can actually represent every element in
the semi group by K elements or you can
just do is look at all cept elections
and choose K produce like count all
those coin combs add them together and
then just see whether you can actually
cover everything so in this generating
function them you can easily do like
intersections but so it doesn't like to
reduce black box to some sort of like
Bartok algorithm it's if you know you
have to like a little bit you have to
work a little bit
you you mean this one here yeah yeah
with this parity arguments then yes
there
[Applause]